Republicans and Democrats in Congress
announced overnight that they reached an
agreement on a massive spending bill
some of the president Trump's key
policies are not included the one
trillion dollar bill would fund the
government through September Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning both parties are
calling this a good agreement with
Democrats in particular crowing about
the fact that they managed to block some
of president Trump's key demands for
instance the deal includes 1.5 billion
dollars for more border security but the
bill specifically states that the money
cannot be used to build a new border
wall the bill keeps funding for Planned
Parenthood in place through September
and Democrats say that it keeps 99% of
funding for the EPA an agency that Trump
mr. Trump had vowed to gut on defense
there is a bump in military spending of
fourteen point eight billion dollars
about half of the 30 billion that the
White House had been asking for other
notable features of the spending package
it permanently extends health care
coverage for coal miners and it provides
sixty eight million dollars to help
reimburse local police forces for their
role in protecting President Trump when
he travels to his homes in New York and
Florida this is the first big bipartisan
piece of legislation moving forward
since President Trump took office and
we're expecting Charlie that the House
and Senate will vote on it early this
week ante